some people would say that anytime we
think of morality it comes from a sense
of ego and that as soon as you dissolve
the ego you dissolve morality there is
no good there is no bad so when you say
that it's not an egocentric manner
but a moral manner that that I I I I am
very hesitant to uh say that morality is
egocentric in in to core are there
theories of morality that are uh yes but
uh I think there are theories that are
antocentric rather than egocentric
um
but can we do that later can we because
I first want to finish this point which
is which is right
um
I'm wrestling with this and the way I'm
wrestling with it is
um
first of all I I
I'm hoping that the work I'm doing
especially with a lot of other people to
integrate these kinds of theoretical
discoveries with ideas about the Deep
connections between predictive
processing relevance realization meaning
in life uh wisdom overcoming
self-deception
all the sapiential stuff we've been
talking about
I'm hoping that because I've been
arguing for the connection that those
two things will stay wedded together
and
um
I don't know if I'm right about that
I uh I I I like sometimes I get like uh
right I don't know if I'm right about it
um but right now I can't see I can't go
back
um and also I think there's so many
there was so much value I mean we
published the paper and we gave what we
thought was the first explanation of the
autism psychosis Continuum rather than
just description to think of the the the
the the the the the you know the the
psychotherapeutic and pedagogical
benefits that could have right so like
it like but
um
I I
do hesitate about this about whether or
not my attempts to keep the science and
the spirituality wedded together
um uh you know there's no teleology to
for that to me I could
me and this whole Community with Sevilla
Kings calls this little corner of the
internet we're trying to do that we
could fail and I think that scares me
okay so don just to repeat
the question was about the limitations
of One's Own theories and then also I
saw your eyes light up on the mention of
morality and ego so you can comment on
that as I decide after it
sure sure so
I'll talk about my theory in just a
second but I'll just I'll just mention a
a classic case which is Einstein's
general relativity with Quantum field
Theory right those theories assume space
time is fundamental in in their
fundamental concepts right Quantum
fields are defined over space time
Einstein's theory of gravity is is the
theory in which space time is
fundamental and its curves are what we
experience as gravity so so space is the
fundamental concept that's going on
there so you might say well how can that
theory then say or it entail that
space-time is doomed without
contradicting itself right I mean how do
we avoid shooting ourselves in the foot
well that's the glory of science because
when you put those theories together
they tell you precisely they say at 10
to the minus 33 centimeters
and 10 to the minus 43 seconds this
Theory stops it no longer makes sense
there are no operational meanings for
space and time at those levels so so
that's the beauty of those theories even
though Einstein didn't expect that to
come out
you didn't even expect black holes to
come out I mean it's the short Shield
found that solution to his equations so
when you take your ideas
even if you're a genius like Einstein
and you put them in mathematics you're
going to have your own Theory come back
and slap you in the face and tell you
things that you that you might not like
Einstein did not like black holes and I
think that he was unhappy with the idea
that that space-time ceased to have
operational meaning at 10 to the minus
33 centimeters my view is
that's what we want from a theory I love
a theory that tells you precisely at
like a 10 to the minus 33 centimeters I
stop and you need something new you need
a new tool so in our theory of conscious
agents so we have a theory of
Consciousness it's a mathematically
precise Theory and those who are
interested if you just Google objects of
Consciousness that's the title of our
paper and my name objects of
Consciousness and Hoffman you'll find
the paper it's it's uh it's
free online so no problem together
so that's a mathematical Theory Of
Consciousness it's just an I don't view
it as the final Theory of Everything as
I said is just a next baby step in
science that's my view of the theory so
here's our next baby step but it's
mathematically precise and so the
question is does it tell me is precise
limits and it does and that's what one
thing that I love about the theory so
one theorem of a theory in this current
formulation is that anytime you have
multiple agents multiple conscious
agents that that collection even if
they're not interacting that collection
satisfies the definition of a conscious
agent so it's a conscious agent
that's just a theorem
and what that theorem entails ultimately
is that there is one conscious agent
because all of the agents that you could
possibly have or combine and they create
a single new agent so there is
ultimately one one agent
but
here's the problem then here's the limit
of our Theory
suppose I start with a countable
Infinity of conscious agents so agent
one two three four all the way up to
Infinity
well so I have this this countable
Infinity of Agents a left zero the
infinity
but now our theorem says that every
possible combination of Agents so agent
one and two one plus two that's an HM
one plus so it's the power set so
there's a a power set of new agents
well we know that the power set has
cardinality alf1 it's a new bigger
infinity
so now let's look at those agents and we
take all their combinations well that's
a new power set that's a lift 2.
so we're gonna have to go to get to a
description of the one
ultimate conscious agent that's the and
it's a theorem of our theory that there
is one conscious agent
we're gonna but to get to it to actually
describe it we're gonna have to climb up
all of cantor's hierarchy now there's an
infinite number of steps in cantor's
hierarchy which means we cannot get
there
so in in 20 000 years if we're still
using this framework and we've gotten to
level five billion of cantor's hierarchy
it's time to break out the champagne we
just we went through 500 billion levels
uh you know where alif 500 billion and
we learned a lot at every level so we
learned something new about
Consciousness every time we transcended
and went to a new level time to break
out the champagne how much further do we
have to go Infinity you're not even
you're not literally you're not any
closer than when you started and yet you
learned a lot and so what I love about
this theory is it says there is the one
conscious agent and number two using
this Theory you'll never be able to
describe it but number three you'll know
precisely how far you've gotten and
precisely how infinitely far you have to
go at every step of the theory so the
theory itself predicts its own failure
to to actually describe an entity that
it's a theorem exists from the theory so
that for me that's one thing I love
about the theory is that it tells me
immediately how far I've gotten and
right now we're just at a left zero we
haven't even gone to lf1 yet
so we have a long way to go
John do you have any comments quickly
yeah
um
I wanna I wanna know more about what is
meant by conscious agents and what is
meant by um the rejection of of
space-time but before I do that
um
I mean the arguments aren't identical
but they converge I mean these are very
in that sense convergent with
neoplatonic arguments that the one lies
beyond all possible
conceptualization uh and uh because
um
if
because if you tried to understand it
you have to understand it in terms of
its structure or its cause and therefore
you haven't actually achieved
um the the the the the the one because
you still would then have to get some
system of intelligibility that explains
the relationship between the structures
and the and so you're always you're
always are pointing towards an Ultimate
Reality
um that uh can't
ever be grasped the source of
intelligibility the arguments go like
the source of intelligibility can't
itself be intelligible
um and what was interesting is it
sounded to me Donald and maybe I'm
getting it wrong it sounded to me like
you got this sort of fractal wanting
going all the way up uh which means even
your notion of the one is in some sense
inadequate and it points Beyond itself
and then the whole trajectory of all
these ones points towards a one that is
never that is never graspable that's
what I heard you saying and that that
sounds like neoplatonism uh through to
me
um profoundly the part about the
conscious agents I want to talk to you
more about but the structure of sort of
you know I should do it this way the
fractal of winning like this or
something I don't know what what gesture
to make with my hands which is quite
adequate but that that is something
disclosed when you reflect deeply upon
intelligibility
um it sounds and by the way Donald I
hope you know that I mean this is a
compliment not an insult I consider
myself a post nominalist neoplatonist so
hearing what sounds like a very new
platonic structure to reality
that really resonated with me
now I wonder what you would say though
and maybe this goes to what you mean by
Consciousness so platinus argues that
the top thing right Consciousness is he
takes intentionality to be a feature of
Consciousness and that therefore
Consciousness always implies a duality
and that you need a one beyond that
Duality to explain
explain the Duality and that therefore
you pass beyond Consciousness and
thought you pass both the
unconsciousness and and intelligence
when you get to the when you get to the
want below it he has you know you
probably know this the new The Noose
which is like all of these ones all
those reforms that and they're they're
like this they're infinitely mirroring
each other like indra's net
um
so I want to I wonder what you think
about that kind of argument but I know
that's an unfair question to just ask
first because it depends on you know
what you're meaning by conscious and
what you're meaning by agent
right so
um and by the way I'll describe it but
of course the paper objects of
Consciousness has the math all laid out
in a shirt but
intuitively right when you're trying to
boot up a theory you want the the
smallest set of assumptions that you can
possibly use that would boot up a
general theory and there's dozens and
dozens of things you could think about
it you want a theory of Consciousness to
deal with you know the self is there a
self yeah learning memory problem
solving intelligence and there's a bunch
of things qualia
possibility of free will there's tons
and tons of things so but we can't throw
in the kitchen sink so what we do is we
try to find the minimal aspects of
Consciousness that we will take as the
Miracles as the as the fundamental
assumptions of our Theory so we took two
we took that there are conscious
experiences
and that conscious experience has
probabilistically affect the other
conscious experiences occurring those
are the and I I just read in the last
few weeks of looking at the modality it
turns out leibniz says the same thing he
beat us by 300 years by saying that
those were the two if he was going to
boot up a theory of Consciousness he
would use those two things the
experiences and probabilistic
relationships among them so so what we
do is we we take that idea that liveness
beat me at uh 300 years ago and we turn
it into mathematics I say a conscious
agent basically is a probability space
of possible experiences
so these this it could be an infinite
probability space so these are all the
possible experiences of this conscious
agent so write down the probability
space and and then I use markovian
kernels which is a very very general
formulation of some probabilistic
relationships so basically we have what
we call perception decision and action
kernels but they're all markovian
kernels and you can take their
composition and just have one more
clothing kernel if you want but we have
then basically a social network of these
probability spaces so related by
markovian kernels
so it's a big Social Network and and
it's a markovian Dynamics and so when
you look at that Dynamics
um It's You Know It that's what we mean
by conscious agent and it is a theorem
of of that that when you have two
conscious agents
um you can take just their tensor
product and you will get a tensor
product of spaces and kernels and so
forth and and you get it it satisfies
the definition of a conscious agent but
but in terms of
Consciousness and some deep thing about
Consciousness and and experience
I realized after we wrote it down that I
was forced by the mathematics to write
down a probability space on which the
experiences took place
so it's just sitting there it's like a
platonic structure just sitting there
what does that so I once later looked
back and said okay well what does that
mean about Consciousness well that's
clearly Consciousness prior to
experience
so that is that's we're forced to write
down in our mathematics a structure that
corresponds to a being without any
particular experience that is happening
so there is but then the markovian
Dynamics is really modeling the play of
forms of experiences that pop up and
down on this fundamental
um being that is timeless and uh
requires no experience it is the field
of potential for all experiences so I
realized later on that that mathematics
nicely intertwines with interpretations
that we see from various spiritual
Traditions but I was I I didn't try to
to you know model the spiritual
Traditions I was forced by mathematics
you can't talk about probability until
you write down the probability space you
just can't do it and so so you're forced
to do this and I realized well the
natural interpretation of that is being
prior to experience and then markovian
Dynamics is the full set of experiences
and now in the the issue about adapting
to space-time and space-time is doomed
what's going on there
um now I'm just going to tell you what
the physicists are saying they will say
the reason why space-time is doomed is
this if you try to make
more and more precise measurements it's
smaller and smaller scales of space like
the position of this electron or
whatever it might be
you need to use radiation say light with
smaller and smaller wavelengths
that's why quantum theory says that as
you use smaller and smaller wavelengths
you're going to have more and more
you're using more and more energy you're
concentrating energy into a smaller and
smaller space E equals H Nu is there is
the formula and that's and in a world
without gravity that's fine as long as
you can get more and more energy even
bigger and bigger Power Station you can
resolve smaller and smaller and smaller
things no problem so space space and
time are fine
gravity messes everything else it's the
you know it crashes the party because
what happens is Einstein tells us that
energy and mass are the same thing so
effectively as you're making finer and
finer measurements you're you're
concentrating more and more mass into a
smaller region so you're getting higher
mass density
and then gravity says at some point when
you get when the mass density reaches a
certain threshold space time collapses
into a black hole and the Very object
that you're trying to measure disappears
and that happens at 10 to the minus 33
centimeters and been 10 to the minus 43
seconds which is the amount of time it
takes to move 10 to the minus 33
centimeters and so so what happened and
so it and it's not like that there are
pixels of space time so a wrong concept
is always say oh well space time is
still fundamental but there are pixels
at that that level no no it means that
space time ceases to be coherent it has
no operational meaning at that level so
it just it's gone it's it's doomed
and another argument that the physicist
will give that's even deeper than the
one I just gave is to say that in
quantum theory the measuring device
itself is a physical device therefore
it's subject to Quantum uncertainty yeah
yes yes and to get more and more precise
measurements you need to add more and
more degrees of freedom to the device
which means it's getting more and more
massive yeah if you're in the lab it's
you know you've got this device in your
lab at some point it's going to be you
know as you get more and more precise
the whole the mass is going to be so
great that the whole Lab collapses into
a black hole and again you destroy the
um the experiment so so there's no
operational meaning to space time and
when the physicists then say okay
space-time has been good it's been
really a great framework for centuries
or you know space end time and then in
the last century space time but it's
time to find something new and they're
the young physicists are moving beyond
and they found these new structures the
amplitohedron and then also the uh
decorated permutations
and these structures
um are Beyond space-time and they're
beyond quantum theory
and when I say they're beyond quantum
theory the amplitohedron has no Hilbert
spaces
but it's phase structure
encodes both locality and unitarity the
properties of space-time and quantum
theory so so this is a structure that
could have trillions or more Dimensions
not just four or eleven it has trillions
of dimensions and it doesn't care about
space it doesn't care about time it
doesn't care about Quantum Theory it
couldn't care less about them but its
volumes actually are
the scattering amplitudes if you want
the two blue ones in four blue ones out
the amplitude Heaton Associated to it
its volume is the scattering amplitude
and a space structure encodes locality
and unitarity
and so
so this is this is a structure Beyond
space-time and and here's the beautiful
thing
when you try to compute these scattering
amplitudes like two glons hitting each
other four glue ones go spring out if
you do it in space time
um well to do it in space time you have
to enforce things the properties of
space and time things you know that have
locality and unitarity and so we have to
you know use what are called Feynman
diagrams to talk about all these virtual
particles that that we need in in
space-time to actually do this math it
turns out two gluons to four gluons
hundreds of pages of algebra hundreds of
thousands maybe millions of terms
to do one event just one event when you
go outside of space-time with the
amplitohedron
that computation reduces to three terms
that you can compute by hand so hundreds
of pages reduced to three terms so
and then all of a sudden the physicists
say by the way we also when we let go of
space-time we see these new symmetries
like something called the infinite
yanging and Symmetry and the infinite
Yang in symmetry is true of the
scattering data and you cannot say it in
space-time so space time is doomed
space-time forces you to do all this
nasty nasty computation that's that's
unnecessary the computations are
actually simple and it hides the
symmetries that are really true of the
data so so space time has three strikes
against it it proves its own uh
you know I mean limits it it makes the
math unnecessarily complicated and it
hides the genuine symmetries that are
there so that's why
um the physicists are moving with both
feet beyond space time and they're
finding this wonderful stuff and and
that's why I as a as this you know a
theorist trying to get a theory of
consciousness
that can lead to testable results which
are only in space-time right the only
place where we can get measurable
experiments is in space-time that's
where we get our measurements so
it's no longer
that I want a theory of Consciousness
that somehow you know emergent from
things in space-time like brains and so
forth that that I mean space-time is
doomed so that whole
that can't work so booting up
Consciousness from stuff inside
space-time the physicists are telling us
that will not work so I'm not going to
try to do that Consciousness is beyond
space time and they've given us this
interface that we have to plug into
they've said we've gone beyond
space-time and the deepest thing we
found is a decorative permutation and so
a few months ago I was sitting there and
saying okay that's what the physicists
want they want to decorate a permutation
if I give them a decorative permutation
they can actually take me all the way
into space-time and give me a scattering
amplitude something I can test something
that you see at the Large Hadron
Collider so can I get from my markovian
dynamics of conscious agents to a
decorated permutation
and I looked online just to say well
surely the mathematicians have done this
you know for any markovian kernel what's
the decorated permutation now look and
they're there's there wasn't anything
and so I work with my my mathematician
pal league chaitan and uh didn't take us
very long we we so it's a new piece of
mathematics we now have a canonical way
of assigning every markovian kernel a
decorated permutation also any arbitrary
graph we can assign arbitrary graphs
decorated permutations
and what this does is it now the
physicists have pushed Beyond space-time
to decorated permutations but it's just
a platonic solid sitting there it's
motionless it's just sitting there
we now offer a Dynamics a markovian
dynamics that projects
so the Dynamics is much more complicated
so if we have for example
um 50 interacting conscious agents
the structure that we get the markovian
structure we get is a Markov polytope
with 50 to the 50th power
uh there's probably more than the number
of atoms in the universe that's the
number of vertices in this polytope
that's describing just 50 conscious
agents interacting so this is an
incredibly complicated structure very
very rich dynamical structure
that projects down that that that
structure which has you know more
vertices than all the atoms in the the
measurable universe
projects down into a decorated
permutation which is only 50 numbers
and that then gives rise to the
scattering so you can see that the the
conscious thing is really complicated
it's a really complicated Dynamic we're
collapsing it down to something trivial
when we get to decorated permutations
and then even more trivial when we get
into space-time
so so Consciousness is fundamental but
we have this map all the way from
Consciousness into space-time and so now
so we're submitting a paper this week so
the we finished writing the paper on
this which is why I'm pretty excited
about it we'll submit it um probably by
you know just before Thanksgiving um you
know Wednesday but we're now we have
this pontoon Bridge from Consciousness
into space-time and now what we're doing
is trying to do you know move all the
heavy equipment across so what what is
you know what
what aspect of consultation Dynamics
corresponds to energy and momentum or to
wavelengths or to spin or to helicity
and and so forth we we in our paper we
start to propose specific
um correspondences between features of
Consciousness and its Dynamics in our in
our model and specific things that you
can measure in space-time because my
goal is to show that you know the space
time is doomed yes
um but there's this dynamics of
Consciousness Beyond space-time and we
can actually predict specific scattering
amplitudes and actually show you where
spin momentum helicity and all these
variables come from and and
I think we can even explain why
supersymmetry is false I think that in
our dynamical model we can actually show
why
um you know for certain models you
um something called n equals four
supersymmetric theories
um the
decorated permutation gives you
everything there is to say about the
scattering amplitude everything but if
you don't have supersymmetry you have to
bring in spin and mass for example and
we can explain from our dynamics of
conscious agents why that is the case
that it turns out that the different
versions of spin are asymmetric and you
can't see it using the standard physics
models but when you go through the
markovian model you actually see that
spin the various kinds of spins have
subtle differences so that they're not
perfectly symmetric and that then blows
out super symmetry so so we're hoping
not just to
um model what the physicists already
know but but to have the model actually
ex you know go go well beyond right
these these Markov polytopes uh have a
richness of structure and in our paper
we're only going to go after M3 the
three agent interaction which has 27 so
it's and it turned out my my colleague
caitan who's the mathematician
um worked very very hard as a beautiful
beautiful structure very very
complicated for just three agents
interacting and it grows extra
financially with five agents there's
three thousand nodes three thousand more
than three thousand vertices it just
grows exponentially and the and the
Dynamics is very very rich so so that's
a little bit about why space time is
doomed and why I think Consciousness is
is more fundamental and why I'm sort of
excited about it
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy